do you know that it's the it's the memo
like maybe I just don't want anyone
maybe no one's like living up to the
plate okay so so
okay well I I just think of this there's
one of you and there's the whole
population of men
so you know what it is I'm sorry to say
but the UK is mid nice no but I think
it's also social media I think people
nowadays they meet someone and then they
you know he can be
um if you're into men like he can be you
know the whole package but because of
Socials you're like oh but he's but he's
but he's but so I feel like a lot of
people struggle to actually like build
something with someone because they're
always thinking there might be something
better out there
no it's because like we're all chasing
after the same men women only sweat
bread and dating apps five percent of
the time
we only we all need that's the number
one way people are meeting dating apps
nowadays we only swipe right which one
so I'm gonna download them
it's true it's true we only swipe right
five percent of the time most women rate
80 percent of men is unattractive not
just okay 80 yeah
I've had I've had hinge before and I
think I've I'm one match yeah and so but
so to me it's treacherous out there but
trenches but that's the whole population
of men so it it says if you're single
over a certain age you're probably too
picky yeah
I mean it's like but that's a choice
it's a choice to be picky yeah yeah
but men let's see okay what percent of
men do you think are six foot then I
mean I've seen this
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
she's above average for women so she has
a choice to Humble her preference me now
I'm actually the average woman had so I
don't see why I should handle my
preference what was the percentage
I think a lot of people are lying that
about their six foot
the whole thing I'm making is women
would rather die alone than get a guy on
their level die alone
again your level is what you can get to
commit to you that's your level
that's your level if you say my
ex-boyfriend was ugly or medium ugly no
no no and you still chose him yeah
definitely I've definitely dimmed my
light a couple times and it still ended
the same that's true
what do you mean dim to your light I've
dated a little bit they're out like I'm
well out their league
no your league is what you did
no no no no no no no no no no no no
you give them the ugliest
guys look at it they are no words guys
we are talking over each other as one
conversation thank you sometimes they
have a little one-two joke and they're
funny and you fall for it and you're
like oh you know what okay so I'll give
you a chance if he's funny that puts him
in the top percentage of guys at
something like the whole point if if you
date him that's the best option you had
at the time you wouldn't you wouldn't
date someone to think you're trying to
sometimes you just want to do something
you're trying something different that's
what it is
you'll sound delusional as hell
that's like wait wait that's like me
saying I'm a millionaire but I don't
have the proof no I don't I have the
proof
like it doesn't count maybe maybe I'll
give you like a 10-year relationship or
something like yeah you know I'll give
you maybe I do think once I do think if
you think you're above someone League
wise you still chose that yourself yeah
you've not chose that like because you
think
um that's that's not your day in any
Lane basically you've done you've done
that for a reason why because you've
done that because you the ones you
normally go for is not working people in
your league are not working
here okay
this is what happens this is what
happens a girl that's a six will date an
eight and he doesn't treat her well
because [ __ ] you're shooting out of your
league if that's out of your opinion
stop stop stop stop stop eight State six
is all the goddamn
time but guys
why are the men that you want not
committing to you
I don't know because it's your
levels
when you're on my level and I'm now
matching you you're gonna take offense
excuses I'm now on part you want to be
some next big man you mean me my babes
so now you want someone who's below me
who can be like yes babe no babe yes
babe yes babe
I bet yes baby what is this leak this
leak sounds like it's all old stuff
I've always said date in your lane right
I've always said this I agree in Daily
which is what you can get to commit to
you no no
it's not what if what if the your ex has
said that about you
this is this is guys this is delusion
because your delusion is different to
mine
you might not be
if you do that one more time we're gonna
sub you out you cannot be over talking
the host you cannot you cannot be over
talking people here
going on please let let's give each
other a chance here thank you
um can I say something I feel like when
we talk about this thing yeah
I feel like a lot of girls nothing
against no one
when I hear you talk about League I feel
like it's all based on looks but for me
personally yeah I'd rather date a guy
that's maybe less attractive but he's
super sweet you know he has his morals
in place he has goals for himself he
he's good for his family like I'd rather
have that than a 10 that has six women
on the side or whatever he's doing
that's right
wait wait go I agree with what you're
saying which is why I disagree with what
you're saying about my exes they have to
have been in my league because the
person they tried to make out they were
because the reason why they're not in my
league isn't just because their their
looks it's based on things like morals
and the person they painted themselves
out to be was a man of their word and I
got to know them and I realized they
want a man that there was I didn't
realize you're not in my league so
therefore what you said is Cap because
it meant I've met they made them
themselves out like yeah if your league
is what you can get to commit to you if
the man that you can get to commit to
you you feel like are below your league
you're delusional yeah the man the man
just because you sleep up doesn't mean
they'll commit to you um
it's delusional it's not because
everyone's different everyone's
different you don't know everyone's
situation so I was actually engaged
about to get married and I called it off
so I wasn't delusional so I was with
someone for six years about to get
married wedding period yeah that's your
level because there's no humidity yeah
yeah
yeah I get that what you mean Commission
because he's the one who obviously
proposed the men proposal because
they're committed yeah I've had people
want to do it and I'm like no because
you're not my guy you're not and if he
committed to you that's your life
I'm saying no because you're not that
guy I'm still waiting for an answer to
what what was it these men that you're
supposedly on the level that you're on
are not committing I didn't see it I was
on a level I'm saying you've got to date
within your lane no you said you did you
said you delayed you you dated below no
I didn't say I did I said people date
below just because they want to try
something different all right so why did
the people that are dating below why why
can't they let them in on their level
because the ones they're trying to on
their level with is not working for them
so you think so you are telling me every
single guy you've did it has always been
the same no but I'm not saying I'm just
going off what you said no and I'm
telling you what I've said
okay I have a question I have a question
okay what how would you know what your
level is if it's if it's not the guy
committing to you because if it's not
the guy committing to you
what would you go off of what else would
you go off of the guys you're sleeping I
gotta like your pictures on Instagram
somebody who is Emily personally would
be someone that even if things didn't
work out because of chemistry because of
maybe small things that we're not into I
can still look at and say you know I
respect him yeah Eve and he has the same
mutual respect for me
I have a question did he commit yes okay
so again it goes back to your level is
what you can get to commit to you as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible